bene tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono parigi oggi sarà su
insulation un gioco dove c'è
protagonista gesù cristo al contrario
new game
allora non devi utilizzare gli iphone
vabbè io ci vivo con gli altri il fatto
ragazzi che stravotato sto gioco quindi
dovrei capire bene quando si parla a
parte un tizio che era sverso fuori
dalla discoteca gior no io ovviamente
avendo più si vede il corpo bellissimo i
giochi dove ti si vede il corpo hanno
una marcia in più ragazzi ceva questo si
è svegliato dal nulla senza avere niente
ma perché la torcia annuncerà in mano
gli si illuminano gli occhi ci vede bene
perché gli occhi parte il flash degli
occhi bellissimi ossia addormentato con
una ripicca uno di quegli elementi che
c'è una torcia in testa però farebbe un
po strano utenti zio con gli occhi
luminosi cosa facciamo qua per aprire la
porta e bisogno della chiave della
chiave della luna
va bene troviamo la questa chiave
dell'anno ragazzo mi sembra c'è un po di
fisso perché questa partenza e proprio
tipo classica degli horror nel 2013 si
proprio classico o ma c'è qualcosa che
sia presto gioco è tutto chiuso
scusate voi che vivete nel buco nel muro
hogan c'è un cane chiamato hogan che
però non c'è premia per interdire il
cibo preferito di hogan del cane ora
verrà mangiare quando sentirà la
campanella ok
questa è la ciotola del cibo ma scusami
perché ho bisogno di carne avvelenata
mia voglia avvelenare il cane che ne sai
mica perché a me piace ma scusami perché
dovrei diverse cover hogan inventario
flashlight perché dovrebbe negare un
cane evaporò cane ma non ho capito ma
poi cristiano di qua il cane peccato
perché a me piace anche un bel nome
bello labirinto molto contenuti sento
passi nei cespugli
hogan situ o gara su un altro partito il
muro organi file kogan sarebbe della
carne da mettere nel gruppo la chiave
della luna ce l'abbiamo trovata vorrei
passare dentro il coso libro credo di
potermi
presenti internet trova i tre bottoni
nel labirinto uno giallo 2 blu 3 rosso
attenzione al guardiano del labirinto la
porta si sblocca quando hai ateo di tre
bottoni giallo blu rosso giallo blu
rosso giallo e quando sento parte che
qua ci sono delle colonne gialle eccolo
giallo hogan
ciao come stai credo che credo che ora
non sia un cane buono o no allora
ascoltami non ti voleva bene ma io vado
a darti rosso sono tranquillo però porca
vacca 11 mette pure the blue ma anche
effettiva mi interroga non ho idea di
dove sia però il cane sta qua va bene
non è proprio il rosso gioco une più
nintendogs prove manca non si dovrebbe
essere qua
ok tutto schiacciato da tornare indietro
hogan per favore fammi passare per
cortesia possono vedere qualcosa una
vita metano hogan aiuto poi tanto non
puoi fare niente perché puoi affrontarlo
scappa rompe per niente devi andare
incontro al suo destino
ok hogan non stare nell'angolo non 6
punizione occhio mi sta seguendo ora mi
ha ucciso io non potevo fare niente
altro che morire in questo in questa
parte di gioco che cosa fai ci siamo
ragazzi allora ha portato tutto la porta
sia aperta si sia aperta
ciao c'è un gatto pure ci manca pure
riga applicato da hogan vai vai a casa
tua vai a casa tua dove entrare nella
porta della luna sporco demonio e che
questo rumore che sentono potessi mangia
qualcosa c'è un bambino che piange no
vabbè pure i bambini ci manca solo
quello fammi uscire mai e che piange
[Musica]
salve c'è un bimbo non piangere che ora
è andato via io io ti voglio io era un
click bates
sì ma è una luce farlocca questa c'è la
porta della luna permesso eccolo lì non
lanciata la chiave con tua band dori
lidia archi la chiave del cuore c'è
posta per te vabbè ma con quale effetto
sonoro del 1800 me lo stai dicendo
ma dall inac leanza rivivere tutto in
questa casa c'è un è tutto un ansia c'è
un cesso bruttissimo però mettete cielo
un bagno quando capita per carità c'è
una vasca piena di sangue anno c'è un
trasmettitore non stava cosa dalla vasca
tra 3 2 1
no è cazzo ridi no no no ma intanto c'è
la torcia mitico nella doccia chiudi la
dolce kg alloggiati la doccia chiusi
chiudi lascia aperta la porta lo si apre
non capisco sia succedendo 6 benvenuto
nella casa no a de marchi l'ho trovata
anche bello bellissimo quadro comunque
non avevo visto l'art chi ha qui posso
entrare bisogno per fare chissà che giro
tutto chiaro abbiamo permesso a pennello
adesso sì che tutto miglior ora ciò sta
che comunque era veramente facile
trovarla archi al è tutto completamente
bianco ancora non ho capito leva bella
starkey cielo quindi era e la facessimo
arrivare qua la pompa il lucchetto
statua erede pedrocchi manca solo quella
chiave del lucchetto le chiavi della
camera
sa che sta lì sopra stadi sopra non so
dove ho attivato la pompa qui adesso
posso andare di sopra prendere la chiave
venir di sotto togliere lucchetto e
aprirla stalking quanto sono bravo
soggiorno eccoci asia perlomeno
avvoltola questa utilizzatissimo non c
entro le fate vedere cosa c'è qua dentro
prima che mi incuriosisce stalking
buongiorno e arrivederci
va bè capisco
ok immaginavo madonna alleanze rivivere
o che è che istanza strana c'è ma per
quale motivo sono delle cose scritte c'è
un cesso alla fine ovviamente ma perché
ma è vivo
no il martello l'ho preso
posso spaccare la porta dei fori però
non ho capito il senso di della fogna a
cielo aperto a fare la foglia io adesso
c'è il martello posso spaccare le cose
che stavano fuori però c'è una fogna qua
che non ho ben capito il senso prove
scendiamo al check point che strano per
questo noi abbiamo mai visto qualcomm
chiude fogne allora io il no no è solo
un diploma io allora nota fakis di
allora non si è chiusa in scusa eh no
quindi non sto capendo cosa devo fare
cosa sta succedendo porca vacca sita 6
bolzano no no no non so che ecco guarda
di melo the white o che il maastricht
del re the box che non li mood token
once the white o qualche muro ma vaffan
l'ho fatta è bellissimo ma allora
evitato ogni tanto mi stupisco di me
stesso devo fare adottare indietro bene
labbra è allegro suo gioco beh mi piace
che pardon e l'armatura meteo ogni suono
ed ai e coste porte hogan
ma no ma poverino oh no
hogan cose non voglio vedere dolgo ma
dai mi toccate i cani anche se mi ha
morso un po un pezzo di merda e data la
mi sta simpatico qualche marco io ho
provato pure a salvarlo ci ho messo la
carne però vabbè gli avanti ragazzi
questo gioco non ha un senso proprio
questo
si è ovviamente chiuso la porta si apre
questa no ok sapete stampa ok potuto
fare qua c'è una porta rossa
so che il frondista il no no no no no no
no no no no no no no mi fico qua sotto
va bene stato e tutto e altezza uomo
perché non mi posso accovacciare capito
no ad ora bisogno di morire salve per
quale motivo basta queste porte alla
slittamento ma dove siamo finiti a cos'è
li avete perso per un cane faccio yoga
adesso poi è semplicemente the ramen
fatto male da aica volta chiusa
sono invece qualcosa dentro la zuppa
ma c'è una chiave dentro sometti
[Musica]